las caravanas de manifestantes siguen su
camino hacia Lima mientras la policía
intenta controlarlos miles de personas
salieron desde varias zonas Rurales del
sur de Perú rumbo a la capital donde
esperan poder hacer escuchar su voz
piden la dimisión de la presidenta Gina
boluarte la disolución del parlamento y
la organización de elecciones inmediatas
estoy emocionado para viajar a Lima
porque la lucha continúa
estamos viajando todos los hermanos
sangre aymara y a la lucha los
manifestantes bloquearon carreteras pero
la policía logró liberar varios tramos
de la Panamericana así como de la vía
interoceánica Este martes la presidenta
pidió a los manifestantes reunirse
pacíficamente a su llegada a Lima
sabemos que quieren tomar Lima por todo
lo que está saliendo en las redes el 18
y el 19
yo los llamo a tomar Lima Sí pero en paz
en calma y los espero en la casa de
gobierno para poder dialogar sobre las
agendas sociales que tiene porque
ustedes bien saben que la agenda
política que están planteando es
inviable desde el ejecutivo el
movimiento de protestas empezó el 7 de
diciembre tras la destitución del
expresidente Pedro Castillo que fue
acusado de un intento de golpe de estado
por intentar disolver el congreso que
iba a reunirse a estudiar su destitución
en medio de acusaciones de corrupción el
gobierno declaró el estado de emergencia
en parte del país para hacer frente a
las protestas que dejan decenas de
Muertos una misión de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
concluyó que había indicios de uso
excesivo de la fuerza por parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad